The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today, we finish up the last
of the basic vector operations.
Today, what we're
going to discuss
is something called the vector
product or the cross product.
And it's a new type of
multiplication, whereby we now
multiply two vectors
to obtain a vector.
You see, the dot product
multiplied two vectors,
but it gave a scalar.
This is why the dot product
was called a scalar product.
Now, the idea is, again, we
can go to the physical world
to seek motivation.
And my only problem with that is
that some of the examples that
motivated this are not
quite as elementary
as the work equals force times
distance formula of last time.
The cross product
does come up in sort
of trivial applications,
in terms of moments,
angular momentum, in
terms of mechanics,
and in more advanced situations,
in terms of the Maxwell
equations where, you may
remember, in physics courses,
going through this
routine of the force
and the flux and the
intensity and what have you.
And at any rate, rather than
waste time-- and I mean,
I use the word waste
here judiciously,
because, for the
purpose of our course,
it is not nearly as crucial
to motivate why we invented
the cross product
physically as it
is to define it mathematically
and to use it structurally.
You see, what I
want to do is simply
get to the crux
of the situation,
discuss the concept
of a cross product,
and simply point out that
if A and B are vectors,
by A cross B-- written this way,
A cross B-- we mean a vector.
Now, here's the kicker again.
As soon as I say vector,
that means to define it,
I have to tell you three
ingredients, namely magnitude,
direction, and sense.
Right?
Now, for the magnitude
of A cross B,
it's simply the magnitude of
A times the magnitude of B
times the magnitude of the sine
of the angle between A and B.
And I'm going to
come back and comment
on that in a few moments,
about the difference
between the sine here versus the
cosine of the previous lecture.
Again, physically, there's
a motivation for this.
As far as we're concerned,
all we have to do is say,
this is what the magnitude
is defined to be.
This is the game.
We define it this way.
Next thing I have to do
is tell you its direction.
And the direction of A
cross B is, by definition,
perpendicular to both
A and B. All right?
Another way of saying
that is in the event
that A and B are not parallel,
then the vectors A and B
determine a plane.
And what we're saying
is that A cross B
is in a vector perpendicular
to the plane determined
by A and B. All right?
By the way, if A
and B are parallel,
they don't determine a
plane, because they coincide.
They have only one direction.
But if A and B are parallel,
the angle between them
is 0 or 180, depending
on whether their sense is
the same or not.
Once the angle is either 0 or
180, the sine of that angle
is 0.
Once one of the factors here
is 0, the whole product is 0.
So in the event that A and B
do not determine the plane,
the magnitude of A
cross B is 0, which
means that A cross B
is the zero vector.
And that's a pretty
trivial situation.
So we just won't even
worry about that.
And thirdly, I must now give
you the sense of A cross B.
And the sense is the
usual right-hand rule,
in other words, the direction
in which a right-handed thread
screw would turn as
A is rotated into B--
and now I have to
be careful because
of this sine situation--
through the smaller angle.
You see, look it.
Notice that this sense
is going to depend
on what-- if you
rotate A into B,
you get the opposite sense
than if you rotated B into A.
And not only that, but
if you rotate A into B
through the larger
of the two angles,
notice that rotating A
into B through one angle--
say the smaller one--
gives you a different sense
than rotating A into B through
the larger of the two angles.
So there's a certain
ambiguity that comes up here.
And the ambiguity occurs
because of the fact
that we're using the sine
rather than the cosine.
In other words, if you
reverse the sense of an angle,
if you change its sine,
the algebraic sine,
the trigonometric
sine, s-i-n changes.
OK?
And similarly, the
sine of an angle
is the negative of the sine of
360 degrees minus that angle.
But that, at any rate,
is the definition
of the cross product.
Given two vectors, their
cross product is what?
A vector whose magnitude is the
product of the two magnitudes
times the magnitude of the sine
of the angle between the two
vectors.
The cross product is
perpendicular to each
of the two vectors.
And it's sense is
the right-hand rule
as the first is
rotated into the second
through the smaller
of the two angles.
This is important
because, you see,
what happens is that as
important as the cross product
is from a physical point
of view, arithmetically,
it's a nuisance.
We can take very few liberties
with the cross product.
It turns out that
almost every rule
that we would like to be true
about numerical multiplication
is false for vector
cross products.
For example, among
other things, A cross B
is not equal to B cross A.
In fact, A cross B is the
negative of B cross A.
And the reason for
this is simply,
as you check this thing
through, A cross B and B
cross A certainly have
the same magnitude.
They have the same
direction, because each is
perpendicular to both A and B.
But notice that the
sense is different.
Namely, A cross B
tells us to rotate A
into B through the
smaller of the two angles.
And in our particular
diagram that
is what, the
counterclockwise direction?
On the other hand, B cross
A says, rotate B into A
through the smaller
of the two angles.
And if we do that, notice that
we get the clockwise direction
so that B cross A and A cross
B have the same magnitude.
They have the same direction.
But they have the
opposite sense.
That is, A cross B is the
negative of B cross A.
And what that means,
you see, in computations
is that every time you
change the order of A and B
in a cross product, you must
remember to change the sign.
In fact, what's
particularly embarrassing is
if you forgot to do this.
If this particular term is going
to be added on to something,
and you forget to
change its sign,
you're going to be off by more
than just the error of a sign.
In other words, if something
was supposed to be plus 4,
and you have it as minus
4 or vice versa, the error
is going to be 8 if you add
it rather than subtract it,
you see.
So the error gets hidden
in other computations.
In other words, you can change
the order of the factors,
but you must remember
to change the sign.
Another interesting thing is
that unlike in the dot product,
where A dot (B dot C)
didn't even make sense,
it is true that A cross (B
cross C) and (A cross B) cross C
do makes sense.
And by the way, what
are these things?
They're vectors.
B cross C is a vector, which is
perpendicular to both B and C.
It's perpend-- you see.
And A is a vector.
And the cross product
of two vectors
is, again, a vector, et cetera.
These are two vectors.
But in general,
these two vectors
do not have to be equal.
In fact, as I shall
show you in a moment,
these two vectors
don't even have
to be in the same plane,
let alone being equal.
They don't even have to
be in parallel planes.
And again, without making
too much of a fuss over this,
let's take a look and
see if we can see why.
Let's look at A
cross (B cross C).
By definition-- let's just
even look at the direction.
Let's not even worry
about magnitudes.
What is the direction
of A cross (B cross C)?
It must be what?
It must be, on the one
hand, perpendicular
to A and on the other hand
perpendicular to B cross C. OK?
That's the definition of
being a cross product.
On the other hand, what about
B cross C as a vector itself?
B cross C is perpendicular
to both B and C.
So what do you have here?
You have that whatever
A cross (B cross C)
is, it's perpendicular to B
cross C, which, in turn, is
perpendicular to both B and C.
That sounds like
a tongue twister.
But if you decipher
it, all it says
is that A cross (B cross
C) is perpendicular
to the perpendicular to B and C.
And I call that deciphering it.
What is the perpendicular
to the perpendicular?
You say let's just
write it this way.
Here are two vectors
in the plane.
Here's a perpendicular.
I now take a
perpendicular to that.
And that's going to be
parallel to the original plane.
This is written up in the text.
It's written up as one of
our learning exercises.
But just for a quick run-through
now, all I want you to see
is that A cross (B
cross C) is parallel
to the plane
determined by B and C.
In fact, the easy
way to memorize this
is look at the vector
that's in parentheses.
And the cross product is what?
It's parallel to the plane
determined by the two
vectors in parentheses.
The only time these two
vectors, by the way,
won't determine a plane
is if they're parallel.
But in that case,
the cross product
would have been zero anyway.
In other words,
to summarize what
I've written on the blackboards
here, A cross (B cross C)
is a vector which lies in the
plane determined by B and C.
After all, if the vector
is parallel to the plane,
you can assume it
lies in the plane,
because you can shift
it parallel to itself.
And correspondingly,
(A cross B) cross
C is a vector in the
plane determined by A
and B. In particular,
there's no reason
why the AB plane
and the BC plane
have to be the same plane.
No law says that our three
vectors, A, B, and C, all
lie on the same plane.
So in particular, this is
why the associative property
doesn't hold for
a cross product.
Because as soon as you
shift the parentheses,
you actually shift the plane
in which the vector exists.
OK?
But again, I just want to
go through these highlights
to make sure that
you don't miss them.
But these are done in
more detail in the notes.
Before I start blasting
the cross product too much,
let me point out that
certain properties that we
like in numerical arithmetic are
present in the cross product.
For example, there
is a-- I say this,
there's a little structure.
The distributive property
holds for the cross product.
In other words,
if the vector A is
crossed with the sum of
the two vectors B and C--
and by the way, again notice,
if B and C are vectors,
B plus C is a vector.
I'll put a v down here
to indicate vector.
A is a vector.
And the cross product of
two vectors is a vector.
Notice that, again,
with the cross product,
all of the things
that you're working
with happen to be vectors.
But my claim is that A
crossed with (B plus C) is
equal to A crossed
with B plus the product
of A crossed with C. That's a
very nice structural property.
Again, as usual,
Cartesian coordinates
have a lot to offer us.
If we switch to Cartesian
coordinates, again, as usual,
writing A as a_1*i
plus a_2*j plus a_3*k,
and B as b_1*i plus
b_2*j plus b_3*k,
and multiplying term by term,
we observe a rather interesting
situation.
You see, notice
things like this.
When you cross i with i,
j with j, and k with k,
you're always going to
get the zero vector.
And the reason for
that is, we already
saw that since the sine
of the angle between two
parallel vectors is 0, the
magnitude of the cross product
is 0, that means that the cross
product is the zero vector.
The question comes
up, what happens
when you cross i with j
or j with i, i with k,
k with j, et cetera?
I think it's easy
to see that when
you cross i and j and
j and i, you're going
to get either k or minus k.
The right-handed rule is set
up very, very conveniently,
again, to help us
with a memory device.
The easiest way to remember how
these things go is i, j, and k
were set up to form
a right-handed rule,
a right-handed system.
Write i, j, and k sequentially.
See, i, j, k, i,
j, k, et cetera.
Call the normal order
the positive direction
and the opposite order
the negative direction.
For example, when you
want i cross j, just read
this list as you go
along: i followed by j
gives k, which is
in the right order--
see, i, j, k-- so
i cross j is k.
On the other hand, j
cross i means what?
j followed by i.
j followed by i is this way.
That also yields k.
But you're now going in
the negative direction.
To summarize these
results, i cross j
is the same as minus
j cross i, which is k.
k cross i is the negative
of i cross k, which is j.
i cross i, j cross j,
and k cross k are all 0.
And notice the use
here of zero vector,
because we're
dealing with vectors.
And again, leaving
the details to you.
They're very simple
to come up with.
Just carry out the
multiplication.
And what you find
is that A cross B
is given by the following.
The i component of the vector
is a_2*b_3 minus a_3*b_2.
The j component is
a_3*b_1 minus a_1*b_3.
And the k component is
a_1*b_2 minus a_2*b_1.
And if you want a convenient
way of memorizing this,
again, write 1, 2, 3 in their
correct sequential order.
And what you're saying
is, each term in A cross B
involves what?
An a factor followed
by a b factor.
The subscripts involve the
component, which isn't present.
See, for the first component,
i, the subscripts are 2 and 3.
For the second component,
j, the second component,
the subscripts are 3 and 1.
And for the third component,
k, the subscripts are 1 and 2.
And notice that the way
the signs are determined
is that if the subscripts
occur in the correct sequential
order, it's positive,
otherwise negative.
For example, 2 followed
by 3 is the correct order.
But 3 followed by 2
is the negative order.
Notice, in this sequence,
1 follows 3, whereas 1 to 3
is in the negative order.
See?
Just the same, this works
out very, very nicely.
And the reason I
went through this--
it may seem like an
awful lot of work
to go through that to show you
how logical this thing is--
is that something comes up in
the textbook, which is not bad,
but which I find as frightening
if you have not had experience
with something
called determinants.
You see, the author,
Professor Thomas,
elects to introduce a
convenient device for memorizing
this result. And he writes
it as a 3 by 3 determinant.
Now, let me just write down
the 3 by 3 determinant,
and then we'll talk
about it later.
I put convenient in quotation
marks to emphasize to you
that this is convenient only if
you already know determinants.
If you don't know
determinants, this
is not only not convenient,
but it's frightening.
We're always
frightened of things
that we don't
understand too well.
And I call it a memory
device, because you do not
have to have
determinants to remember
this particular
result. In fact, if one
were going to list, in order,
the reasons for inventing
determinants, and the
man was reading off
of very, very long list,
and you were getting bored,
as soon as he came to the reason
that it was convenient to list
the cross product, you could
heave a sigh of relief,
because you would know that
he's near the end of the list.
In other words, to
make a long story
short, of all the reasons
for inventing determinants,
using them for a cross
product representation
is perhaps the
least significant.
But you see, in Professor
Thomas's approach,
determinants are
assumed to be known.
And if you do know them,
it's a good notation.
If you don't, forget it.
The trouble is, I
tell you to forget it,
and you won't forget it.
It always works that way.
When you tell the student not
to forget something, he forgets.
When you say, please
ignore it and forget it,
he doesn't forget.
So since you may be a little
bit rusty on determinants,
let me give you a very, very
brief review of determinants.
In fact, it's not only very
brief, it's a pseudo-review,
because I will give you no
logic behind this at all.
I'm just going to
tell you the recipe.
First of all, by a
2 by 2 determinant,
you mean a square array
of numbers consisting
of two rows and two columns.
You use absolute value signs
to indicate the determinant.
And by definition, the
2 by 2 determinant a, b;
c, d is the product of
the two terms a and d,
minus the product of
the two terms b and c.
In other words, if you multiply
the upper left by the lower
right and subtract from
that the upper right times
the lower left, that is, by
definition, the value of the 2
by 2 determinant,
just by definition.
By the way, in block
seven of our course,
we're going to do this
in much more detail.
For now I just want to
give you enough of a hint,
so that if you are
frightened by determinants,
you can see what Professor
Thomas is talking about
in the text here.
Now, to expand a 3
by 3 determinant,
one uses a little sign code.
Starting at the upper
left-hand corner,
you put a little plus sign.
Then you alternate plus,
minus, plus, et cetera.
The plus simply is a
code to tell you, leave
the sign of the term alone.
And the minus tells you,
change the sign of the term.
What that means is this.
By definition, this
3 by 3 determinant
is obtained as follows--
take x_1 as it appears
and strike out the row and
column in which x_1 appears
and multiply x_1 by the
remaining 2 by 2 determinant.
Then what you do is you factor
out x_2 with a minus sign,
strike out the row and
column in which x_2 appears,
and multiply x_2
by the remaining 2
by 2 determinant that's left.
Similarly, take out x_3 with
the sign that it appears with,
strike out the row and
column in which it appears,
and multiply by the
remaining 2 by 2 determinant.
Summarized, to expand
this 3 by 3 determinant,
it's x_1 times the determinant
y_2, y3; z_2, z_3 minus x_2
times the determinant
y_1, y_3; z_1, z_3,
plus x_3 times the determinant
y_1, y_2; z_1, z_2.
Now, that happens to have
very practical application.
As I say, for this
particular situation,
I just want to do it with you
to have you see how it works.
Let me come back to what
we were doing before,
and show you how, if
we use this definition,
we can mechanically write
down A cross B in a hurry.
What did the rule say?
It says, to expand the
3 by 3 determinant,
take out i, as it appears,
and multiply by the 2
by 2 determinant that's left,
when you strike out the row
and column that i appears in.
OK?
Then it says what?
Take out j with a minus sign,
strike out the row and column,
multiply by the remaining
2 by 2 determinant.
Then it says, factor out k and
strike out the row and column
that k appears in.
Multiply by the remaining
2 by 2 determinant.
Well lookit, by our
rule of multiplying a 2
by 2 determinant, what
is this thing here?
This is nothing more than
a_2*b_3 minus a_3*b_2.
I'm not going to go through
this, because time is short
and you can carry this
operation out by yourself.
What I would like
you to see, however,
is that this term here
is precisely the same
as the term we have here.
In other words, if I carry
out this mechanical recipe,
I am going to be able to
get the same answer that I
got logically, only without
having to worry about keeping
track of things in my head.
In other words, if I
do know determinants,
it is very convenient
to write down
the cross product of two vectors
using Cartesian coordinates.
And just to illustrate that,
let me give you a few examples.
I call this example one.
Find the vector
perpendicular to the plane,
determined by the three
points, (1, 2, 3); (5, 9, 4);
and (7, 6, 8).
Now, try to visualize
this problem
if you didn't know vectors.
Try to visualize drawing
this thing to scale,
trying to imagine what
slope the plane has
and how you find a
vector, or a line
perpendicular to the plane.
And by the way, I don't even
need the word vector in here.
Later I could say,
find a direction.
But we'll worry about
that more next time.
The thing that I want
to emphasize here
is, I just very
quickly draw myself
a little convenient device.
I don't draw it to scale.
I assume that the points
A, B, and C are not
in the same straight line.
And if they are, it'll
become very interesting
that I simply won't get--
I'll get 0 for a cross product
to tell me that they don't
form two non-parallel vectors.
But I mark off A, B, and C.
And the first thing I do,
as always, is I vectorize--
I draw the lines AB and AC,
and I vectorize them.
That forms for me, as usual,
the vector AB and the vector AC.
Remembering how I
form a vector from two
points in Cartesian
coordinates, again,
subtracting the
coordinates of the point
that I'm going-- from the
point that I'm going to,
I subtract away the coordinates
of a point that I'm leaving.
In other words, 5 minus
1, 9 minus 2, 4 minus 3.
The vector AB, very simply,
is 4i plus 7j plus k.
And similarly, the vector
AC, very conveniently,
is 6i plus 4j plus 5k.
You see, 7 minus 1,
6 minus 2, 8 minus 3.
Now, I better stop
checking these things.
Because, with my luck, I've
probably subtracted wrong,
and you might not notice it if
we just go through it rapidly.
But look at how quickly
I've got AB and AC now.
Now, here's the beauty.
What do I want?
I want a vector
perpendicular to the plane
determined by A, B, and C.
In particular, if I can find a
vector perpendicular to both AB
and AC, namely if a vector
is perpendicular to two
lines in a plane, it's
perpendicular to the plane
itself.
If I can find a vector
perpendicular to both AB
and AC, I'm home free.
That's the vector
I'm looking for,
or at least a vector
that I'm looking for.
Do I know, conveniently,
a vector perpendicular
to two given vectors?
And the answer had darn
well better hinge somehow
on the title of today's lecture,
being the cross product.
Yes, by definition, if I
cross AB and AC, whatever
vector I get is going to be
perpendicular to the plane
determined by A, B, and C.
And now what I'm saying
is that the beauty
of Cartesian coordinates is that
I can now very quickly write
down what AB cross AC
is as a determinant.
Namely, I write down i, j, k.
Then I write down
the components of AB.
the components of AC.
See, 4, 7, 1; 6, 4, 5.
And now I do what?
I strike out the row and
column in which i appears.
And the remaining 2 by
2 determinant is what?
7 times 5 minus 1 times 4--
in other words, 35 minus 4.
I take out minus j, strike
out the row and column
in which j appears.
The remaining 2 by 2
determinant is 4 times
5, minus 1 times 6-- in
other words, 20 minus 6.
I strike out the row and
column in which k appears.
The remaining 2 by 2 determinant
is 4 times 4 minus 7 times 6.
That's 16 minus 42.
And now simplifying,
what do I have?
I have 31i minus 14j minus 26k.
In other words, the vector
31i minus 14j minus 26k
is the vector that
I'm looking for.
It's a vector
perpendicular to the plane.
And what I would like you
to see is how convenient
this vector arithmetic is
to studying space geometry.
And in the next
lesson, I'm going
to say some more
about space geometry.
But for now I thought
maybe another nice example
before we finish up,
and let it go at that.
Let me just do one
more example for you.
And to simplify
the computation, I
might as well use the
vectors I've already used.
Let's take the same
three points we had
before, (1, 2, 3);
(5, 9, 4); (7, 6, 8).
And we're going to ask, what
is the area of the triangle
determined by
these three points?
And the subtlety that I
wanted to bring out here
was an excuse to show
you how the magnitude
of the cross product of two
vectors can be interpreted.
Namely, look at two vectors.
All right?
Call them x and y.
Draw them in to scale
from a common point.
And let theta be the angle
formed between these two
vectors.
Consider the parallelogram
formed by these two vectors.
The area of a
parallelogram is what?
It's the base times the height.
Now, lookit.
The base of this parallelogram
is the magnitude of y.
And the height of
this parallelogram--
remember, this magnitude is x.
So this height is x sine theta.
This is the area of
the parallelogram.
But notice that this
is also, by definition,
the magnitude of x cross y.
In other words, notice that
this is, by definition,
the magnitude of
x cross y. x cross
y is a vector whose
magnitude is this.
In other words, the
magnitude of x cross y
is the area of the parallelogram
determined by x and y,
which gives you a rather nice,
interesting interpretation.
Imagine, for example, that x
and y don't change in length.
Is it clear to you that as
I change the angle between x
and y, the area of
the parallelogram
formed by x and y changes?
In other words,
one extreme case is
when the angle between x
and y is 0, in which case
the parallelogram has no area.
Another extreme case is when
the angle between x and y
is 90 degrees.
In other words, x and y are
perpendicular to each other.
But if the lengths
of x and y remain
fixed, as I alter the
angle between them,
I alter the area of the
parallelogram determined
by them.
All right?
I just thought that's a
cute little device whereby
you can visualize how the
magnitude of the cross product
of two vectors varies.
Think of the two vectors
at a common origin,
and the magnitude is affected by
the area of that parallelogram
as the angle changes.
OK?
In other words, if
you change the angle,
the area of the
parallelogram changes.
But at any rate, getting
back to our original problem,
the corollary to that
is the following.
We already know what
the magnitude of AB
cross AC is from example one.
But what does that mean
now, geometrically?
From what we've just
seen, the magnitude of AB
cross AC is the area of
the parallelogram, which
has AB and AC as edges.
Notice that that parallelogram
is precisely one-half-- I
shouldn't say that-- the
triangle that we're looking for
is precisely one-half
the parallelogram.
In other words, notice that
the area of the triangle
is simply 1/2 the
magnitude of AB cross AC.
How do we find the
magnitude of AB cross C?
We square each of
its components,
add them, and extract the
positive square root, as usual.
Without going
through the details,
it's simply going to be what?
This particular amount.
And the rest is arithmetic's
baby, so to speak.
All right?
Now, what I'm hoping is that
by this stage of the game,
you now have a better
feeling as to what
the cross product means.
Going back to the
beginning of my lecture,
notice that I played down
the physical applications.
Because one of the things
that I wanted you to see
is that the cross product
has tremendous application,
just to space geometry alone,
quite apart from anything else.
Well, at any rate, what
I'm going to do next time
is-- now that we've talked
about lines and planes
and what have you-- to get down
to the Cartesian representation
of what lines and
planes would look like.
They play a very vital role
in the study of functions
of several variables.
We'll see more about that as
the course continues to unfold.
So until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.